philadelphia's district attorney is
getting national attention
in the fight against wrongful
convictions more wrongfully incarcerated
people were exonerated
of murder in philadelphia county last
year than anywhere else in america
since taking office in 2018 d.a larry
krasner
has exonerated 15 people jerika duncan
first spoke to krasner more than a year
ago
and checked in over the summer to hear
about reforming his office's culture
she's also caught up with one of those
15 exonerated people
terence lewis jerica good morning
good morning to understand terence's
terrence lewis's story rather you have
to go back
to 1999. he was 20 years old and
found guilty of second degree murder
sentenced to life in prison
well last year philadelphia prosecutors
dropped those charges
it's now been a year since terrace lewis
was released
at that moment that was that was sheer
genuine joy in may of 2019
after more than two decades behind bars
forty-year-old terence lewis walked out
of a pennsylvania prison
a free man coming from
the box of despair you know where i was
being warehoused
to be able to feel the breeze on that
side of the wall
and to get a genuine hug surreal
i was convicted of that reality was just
starting to set in when we first met
lewis last year
87 days after his release although i'm
grateful
is it's definitely been difficult
because i have been enslaved you know
mentally as well as physically it's been
over a year since you were released from
prison how do you feel
i would be remiss to say that you know
life has been a cakewalk initially it
felt like i was
leaving one prison to come home to
another prison
in 1999 lewis was convicted of
second-degree murder
and sentenced to life in prison
prosecutors built their case around the
testimony of one eyewitness
a drug addict i proved my innocence
unequivocally speaking
factually speaking it wasn't until 21
years later
and after the da's office expressed
quote really grave concerns about
whether lewis was guilty
that a judge threw out his conviction
and ordered lewis's freedom
i got the weights and i just zoned out
some out
think about freedom he sued the city of
philadelphia
that's because exonerees are not
automatically entitled to compensation
in pennsylvania
lewis alleged that police practices
including coercion suppression of
exculpatory evidence
and fabrication of evidence violated his
constitutional rights
this past june the city and lewis
reached a settlement
for 6.25 million dollars
i did 21 and a half years for a crime
that i did not commit
no money in the world can amount to what
i felt inside
he says he's using some of that money to
fight for justice
launching the terrence lewis liberation
foundation it's going to be our first
presentation
a non-profit partnering with u-pen
students to investigate claims
of wrongful convictions he has a sincere
belief
that there are innocent people sitting
in jail now which is surely true
lewis was inspired by philadelphia's
district attorney larry krasner
his conviction integrity unit helped
restore lewis's freedom
but krasner made it clear from day one
he wanted to take on
the entire system in his first week in
office in 2018
he fired 31 employees i did not enjoy it
but it was necessary to do especially as
i see these exonerations happen and
guess whose names
just keep coming up for having been
involved in convictions of innocent
people the people you let go
yep that story will be developing stay
tuned
i can tell you a lot of what has done
since i said stay tuned it's been in the
nature of education we put a ton
of time into educating the prosecutors
about things like the obligation to turn
over
information that helps the defense do
you feel you've done an effective job at
changing that
culture i feel we have although it's a
struggle
and we've had the opportunity to become
credible
within the system to people who may have
had misconceptions about what we were
trying to do
we are just as focused on going after
serious gun violence
as we are focused on making sure
innocent people do not sit in jail
out of a dozen shootings but gun
violence has spiked in philadelphia
since last year homicides have increased
about 40 percent
how do you convince people that you are
just as serious about
focusing on homicide at a time where
philadelphia is facing some of the worst
violent crime in over a decade let's be
fair about this
almost every big city in the united
states is in the same position
why do you think that is well i think
there's no question that it's related to
the pandemic for the first time
in probably close to 100 years we have
the philadelphia court system shut down
for months you have changes in policing
so that police
are making decisions not even to arrest
for certain offenses
when you have all of that going on you
have a perfect storm
in spite of that storm there is hope
says terence lewis
that no matter how long it takes justice
is possible i'm a believer from amongst
the believers in regards to
reform and eradicating the racial
disparities
and inequalities i'm very hopeful that
change in fact
is going to come the philadelphia police
department declined to comment on
lewis's case as you can hear and
tell that lewis is really focused right
now on his foundation
in helping other people like himself
tony
it's a powerful story thank you very
much we were talking about larry krasner
here at the table jericho
very very touched very moved very
thankful that he's taken the position
that he has
is he getting a lot of support
he is getting support from those who
support the ideas that he's talking
about and i think it's still
considered radical maybe not in
philadelphia but when you look across
the country
in terms of what he had to say even when
i asked him about
you know defunding the police and that
idea and him wanting to focus
more on not just putting people behind
bars
but really understanding why they're
there to begin with and looking at other
ways that we can use money
to fund schools to fund programs that
will keep people
from behind bars and listen the story of
terence lewis is a classic example
yeah and why this is so important i was
worried about him because he said he
goes from the box of despair
to almost going into another prison he
seems to be doing okay is he i mean
clearly
he has a you know money isn't going to
make the difference for what was taken
from him but i sure am glad he got some
money yeah